[Applaudissements]
oui
nous attendons ce moment depuis très
longtemps et voir si ces deux bébés
naître est en parfaite santé c'est
complètement dingue
c'est un pas de plus pour la
conservation de l'espèce c'est ce sont
des millions de français qui vont être
sensibilisés encore plus à la protection
et de conservation d'autres biodiversité
en danger
c'est complètement dingue c'est une
chance incroyable là à cette heure si je
peux dire qu on est très content parce
qu'on a deux bébés deux beaux bébés qui
sont tous les deux bien vivace toutes
les deux je l'aurais hier des vivaces
deux petites filles a priori une 2 149 g
une de 128 g presque 120 plein et qui
sont toutes les deux en pleine forme
bien rose
vive les le bébé panda en fait est très
fragile
après la naissance c'est une petite un
petit être sans poils donc pas capable
de se maintenir sa chaleur en fait il a
les yeux fermés ça se passe pas tout
seul donc voilà il faut y faire
attention
là où on sait qu'on a de la chance c'est
que on a deux bébés qui sont déjà d'un
poids très correcte et que roanne ouanna
bien meilleur comportement qu'en 2017
en 2007 c'était une bonne maman elle
voulait en tout cas être une bonne maman
était très bas assez maladroite elle
savait pas trop comment se positionne
elle savait pas trop comment prend le
petit sur elle ce matin là déjà elle et
on sent qu'elle a beaucoup plus les
gestes les les réflexes
[Musique]